and we are going to begin in the state
of Arizona where Chris Van Cleave is the
Grand Canyon State Chris good morning to
you there's a gulf there in the Grand
Canyon but the candidates for Governor
also sent it very very close good
morning
well good morning Tony and ideologically
the golf is huge between the Republican
and Democratic candidates here we should
tell you the polls in Arizona opened
just about five minutes ago there was a
line of people outside of this polling
place in Paradise Valley some folks got
here about a half an hour before the
polls open at 5 30 in the morning here
now the majority of arizonans actually
vote early predominantly by mail we know
more than 1.5 million have essentially
already voted now that said election
officials expect it to be a busy day
here at the polls people voting in
person there's been a lot of emphasis
put on that by the Republican candidates
here in Arizona so they expect a busier
than usual day at the actual polls so be
watching that the key races are thought
to be very very close Kerry Lake the
Trump endorsed Republican candidate for
governor has drawn national attention
for among other things denying the
outcome of the 2020 election an election
run by her opponent Arizona Secretary of
State Katie Hobbs the race for Senate is
one and CBS News calls a toss-up the
former Naval pilot and Astronaut Mark
Kelly the incumbent Senator has made
protecting seniors and a woman's right
to choose key parts of his campaign his
opponent Republican Blake Masters has
gotten a last-minute bump in the polls
while appearing with Kerry Lake as
they've been crisscrossing the state
election officials caution that if these
races are as close as some think or
particularly if they're as close as we
saw here in 2020 it could take several
days to have enough votes counted to be
able to clearly point to a winner some
of that is due to the way that the
mail-in ballots come in you know votes
that arrived Sunday Monday today they
have to go through a verification
process to verify the signatures that
takes time so they may not be counted
until Wednesday Thursday even Friday in
some places Democrats here in Arizona
and across the country are saying they
don't know in many races if they'll be
able to determine who won tonight they
say they're also preparing for some of
their opponents to declare Victory
anyway so that's something we'll be
watching here in Arizona tonight Tony
uh Chris it's a great point a a slow
count is still a secure count and people
should be patient we may not have
results particularly nationally for a
few days uh maybe even longer Chris
thank you very much